how have congressional elections changed
over time congressional elections used
to be separate from the presidential
elections one of the great examples is
in 1938 FDR who we all look back and
think of as a president who had such
extraordinary power and who could do no
wrong well in 1938 he tried to see if he
could exercise that power so he tried to
kick some Democrats out of the
Democratic Party who didn't agree with
him and he was spectacularly
unsuccessful lots and lots of the
Democrats he put his finger on and told
his fellow Democrats you vote for my man
and they lost other Democrats won and
that gives you a sense of how the
president even a popular and successful
one was very separate from his own party
well what's happened since then is that
presidents have heart started to have
much more control over the members of
their own party and voters who in 1938
thought it was outrageous that a
president would force Democrats of his
own party to vote the way he wanted them
to because they saw such a separation
between the presidency and the and the
Congress those voters don't exist much
anymore voters now pay penalize a member
of a party who doesn't stick with their
president of that same party so that
connectedness tends to create a
situation in which congressional
elections in the midterms tend to be a
referendum on the president even though
the president's not in the ballot what's
also the other big change in American
politics is the amount of money in 2018
it's very likely that according to the
Center for Responsive Politics five
billion dollars will be spent on the
election ten years ago in in the
election of 2008 spending was half that
2.5 billion dollars and that was a
presidential year in which there's more
spending the enormous amount of money
means you have more ads you means you
have a whole group of people whose job
it is to make decisions that are subtle
and complicated and complex seem easy
and and and to to intensify the partisan
battles between each other and that also
creates a situation in which candidates
are always running for office because
they're always having to raise the money
to pay for all of those ads and all of
those experts and all of those
Oh media campaigns speaking of social
media we now have an instance in which
you have real tongue named up or down
votes from constituents and people on
the sidelines telling members of
Congress whether they're doing the right
thing or doing the wrong thing either in
office or in elections and that creates
a real-time jitteriness to elections it
used to be you could have a long time
conversation heck when when abraham
lincoln and stephen douglas debated in
those famous lincoln-douglas debates for
a Senate seat those debates took place
over three hours now we have situations
where people will flame up for about 20
minutes on Twitter and that's all the
time you'll ever see for something to be
get addressed because 10 more issues
have come along in the next 20 minutes
so social media has sped up and
intensified the nature of conflict in
campaigns and those are some of the big
big things that have changed in the way
we run our congressional campaigns